♪♪
Narrator:
FRIEND OF THE SHOW MARK ROBER
IS BACK WITH A HOT NEW TAKE
ON THE HOT TUB.
I'M SITTING IN A HOT TUB FILLED
TO THE BRIM WITH SOLID SAND.
[ LAUGHS ]
WHAT?!
Narrator: MARK IS TURNING
SOLID SAND INTO A LIQUID,
AND IT'S MAKING A SPLASH ONLINE
WITH OVER 24 MILLION VIEWS.
THIS IS JUST INCREDIBLE.
[ INDISTINCT SHOUTING ]
I REALLY WANT ONE OF THESE
IN MY HOUSE.
NO, SERIOUSLY, I DO WANT ONE OF
THESE [Laughing] IN MY HOUSE.
Narrator: WE'RE HOT-FOOTING IT
OVER TO CALIFORNIA
TO TAKE A DIP
INTO OUR FIRST QUANTUM LEAP.
I WANTED TO CAPTURE THE TRUE,
LIKE, FIRST REACTION
OF WHAT IT FELT LIKE
WHEN WE TURNED IT ON,
AND SO WHEN I'M SITTING THERE
AT THE BEGINNING,
THAT'S LEGITIMATELY THE FIRST
TIME THAT WE TURNED IT ON.
[ LAUGHS ]
AND THE SENSATION OF JUST
SITTING ON SOMETHING
THAT'S COMPLETELY SOLID
AND THEN, SUDDENLY,
IT JUST LIQUIFIES.
IT'S A CRAZY, WEIRD,
WEIRD FEELING.
THE WHOLE BUILD TOOK US
ABOUT 2 MONTHS.
I'D SAY HALF OF THAT WAS JUST
DOING THE PROTOTYPES
AND GETTING ALL OF THAT,
LIKE, FIGURED OUT,
THE GENERAL PRINCIPLES,
AND THEN THE OTHER HALF WAS
ACTUALLY BUILDING THE HOT TUB.
Narrator:
NO, IT SURE WASN'T QUICKSAND,
SO HOW DID MARK UPGRADE
THIS HOT SAND PIT?
MARK HAS MADE WHAT IS KNOWN
AS A FLUIDIZED BED.
Parker: THIS IS WHERE AIR IS
PUMPED THROUGH THE SAND,
WHICH MAKES IT BEHAVE
LIKE A LIQUID.
WHEN THE AIR IS SWITCHED OFF...
[ LAUGHS ]
...IT RETURNS TO BEHAVING
MORE LIKE A SOLID.
IT JUST STOPS, AND YOU'RE,
LIKE, LOCKED IN PLACE.
MARK HAS 18 COPPER PIPES
THAT RUN SIDE BY SIDE
AT THE BOTTOM OF THE HOT TUB.
INTO THESE, HE'S DRILLED
OVER 2,500 HOLES
WHICH ARE REGULARLY SPACED
AND ALL POINTING DOWN
SO THE SAND DOESN'T
GET STUCK IN THEM.
THOSE PIPES ARE WELDED
TO ONE BIG PIPE
THAT'S CONNECTED TO THREE
CYLINDERS OF NITROGEN GAS.
THEN MARK FILLS THE HOT TUB
WITH OVER ONE TON OF DRY SAND.
Narrator: BUT HOW DOES HE MAKE
THE SAND ACT LIKE A LIQUID?
WHEN MARK OPENS
A NITROGEN CYLINDER,
THE GAS GOES BETWEEN
THE SAND GRAINS,
REDUCING THE FRICTION
IN BETWEEN THEM.
THE GAS PROVIDES AN UPWARD FORCE
ON EACH GRAIN OF SAND
WHICH COUNTERACTS
THE FORCE OF GRAVITY.
Elliott: SO IF THOSE TWO FORCES
ARE IN EQUILIBRIUM,
THE SAND JUST HOVERS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
THE GAS FLOW HAS TO BE JUST
RIGHT TO ALLOW THE SAND GRAINS
TO MOVE FREELY OVER EACH OTHER.
IF THE GAS IS COMING OUT
TOO QUICKLY,
IT WILL GIVE TOO MUCH FORCE
TO THE GRAINS OF SAND,
AND THEY WILL FLY OUT
OF THE HOT TUB.
TOO LITTLE GAS, AND THE SAND
WON'T REALLY MOVE AT ALL.
I CAN'T GET IT OUT.
WHAT'S SO WEIRD IS THAT
WHEN YOU PULL YOUR HAND UP,
OR YOU GET OUT, LIKE,
IT'S COMPLETELY DRY.
LIKE, THAT'S THE PART
THAT'S LIKE,
"WHAT IS HAPPENING?
LIKE, THIS ISN'T QUITE RIGHT."
CUT IT.
AH!
[ LAUGHTER ]
THIS LOOKS LIKE A LOT OF FUN
UNTIL YOU HAVE TO GET SAND
OUT OF PLACES.